democrats passed the equality act in the
house and rand paul grills a biden
nominee
about whether government can overrule
parents seeking to prevent their kids
from transitioning i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by express vpn
stand-up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news of the day
with regard to the equality act
and the transgender propaganda that is
now being put forth
you are just expected to buy into the
over lie that men and women are exactly
the same in every way
and that men and women are terms of art
and that subjective
self assessment as your own sex actually
matters more than you know
actual biological reality we'll get to
all that in just a second because
what we are living through is uh
something that is completely upside down
it's bizarre it's upside down it's
ridiculous even the very notion
that the people who are being imposed
upon here are members of the
trans community as opposed to you know
religious institutions
everyday americans who would like to
operate their businesses as they see fit
all of this is completely upside down
we're gonna get to that in just one
second first the breaking news this hour
is that the united states has now bombed
syrian facilities used by an
iranian-backed militia these would be
the first airstrikes under biden so
quick note bombing syria is good again
remember if
trump does it it's very very bad and if
trump knocks out kasem soleimani the
head of the iranian terror regime that
is super bad
but if joe biden fires a missile at an
empty structure in syria and hits a
camel in the ass that is absolutely
wonderful
it is good and it is useful the same
people in the administration by the way
jen sackey who today will be out there
defending this activity
was sending tweets just a couple of
years ago talking about how trump didn't
have
any sort of congressional authority to
fire anything
at anything in syria right syria was a
sovereign country according to gen saki
apparently when a democrat is president
all you have to do is slap a black lives
matter label on a missile and suddenly
the missile is good
that's basically the way this works all
you have to do
is just stencil in trans lives matter
on the front of a bomb and you can drop
it wherever you want
and that's how it was during the obama
administration right you just put a
bunch of
progressive slogans on the drones and
everything is fine so we are back to
that which is a lot of fun
according to usa today us airstrikes
targeted bases in syria used by iranian
militant groups suspected of attacking
american and allied forces in northern
iraq last week the pentagon announced
late thursday now
as we talked about last week it was
pretty obvious i mean remember
it is now fridays this means it's been
over a week since that original attack
that happened
in iraq right iraq syria and iraq
different countries you may have noticed
but
the biden administration said literally
nothing about that attack on an american
facility
in iraq why because they were deeply
afraid
that if they mentioned this that it
might drive a wedge between the united
states government and the iranian
government
they were afraid that if they said hey
look the iranians are active in iraq and
they're pursuing terror
against americans in iraq then that
might end
all this iran nuclear deal bullcrap
because it is top priority for the
biden administration to re-enter the
horrible and ridiculous
iranian nuclear deal which basically
gives iran a pathway to a nuclear bomb
within 10 years
so long as they pledge they will they
will absolutely give their boy scout
pledge
that they are not going to develop
nuclear weapons for the next 10 years
and we will hand them a bunch of money
they can then use for ballistic missile
development and terrorism
so this had made the iran deal had made
the obama administration essentially the
pr wing of the iranian government
every time iran did something bad obama
and team would be out there
downplaying it pretending it had nothing
to do with the iranian regime well now
they're doing the same thing
so there's an attack on american troops
in iraq by the iranians
and their reaction is to hit an
iranian-backed militia in syria
why in order to obscure the fact that
really it is iran behind
all of this stuff in the first place so
what exactly did they do
apparently the strikes hit multiple
targets used by the militias the
pentagon blames for rocket attacks
on a base in northern iraq they killed
the contractor and wounded us us and
allied troops right they wouldn't hit
iran and they wouldn't hit anything
inside iraq they went to this country on
the other side
of iraq not iran and they decided they
were going to hit a camel on the butt
according to pentagon spokesman john
kirby the operation sends an unambiguous
message president biden will act to
protect american and coalition personnel
at the same time we've acted in a
deliberate manner that aims to
de-escalate the overall situation in
both eastern syria and iraq so basically
we are just going to signal that we are
a little mad but not too mad
i'm confident in the target when after
we know we had said defense secretary
lloyd austin
he said we're confident the target was
being used by the same shield militants
that contr
that conducted the strikes in the first
place
so republicans are largely backing the
strikes because republicans are fine
with
terror outposts being hit and that's
fine i don't have a problem with the
terror outpost being hit either
all i'm pointing out is that they are
hitting the wrong target okay they are
hitting
bases in syria when the real problem is
in iraq
and the real problem is in iran and they
are doing so in order to obscure the
connection between what is happening in
syria and the iranian bosses with whom
they are negotiating because it's very
difficult to make the case to the
american public
then we need to be fighting the iranians
who are attempting to kill american
troops at the same time that we are
giving them a pathway to a nuclear
weapon and funding their terror program
so instead biden's going to obscure that
by doing what democrats very often do
which is fire a missile pinpoint strike
right the way pin prick strike the way
that barack obama
did and then claim that you're being
muscular in your own defense of your
country
alrighty so that is the biden foreign
policy in a nutshell meanwhile
in bigger news for the united states the
house has voted to pass the equality act
okay the equality act is one of the most
egregiously misnamed orwellian
act in modern american history it is not
about equality
it is about imposition on americans of a
standard that is unreasonable
is about ensuring that religious
americans are not allowed to practice
their religion
it is about ensuring that non-religious
americans who believe in a
differentiation between men and women
are completely silenced under american
law that is what equality act is about
the way it is proposed of course is an
anti-discrimination law now
there are already anti-discrimination
laws that exist on the basis of sexual
orientation
and sex this would add gender identity
and gender orientation and a wide
variety of other pregnancy
it would add all of these to the civil
rights act of 1964.
that all sounds fine because of course
nobody wants people
unduly discriminated against when i say
unduly i mean it is not discrimination
to tell a man that he should be using a
man's bathroom
that's not undue discrimination right
that is discriminating in the sense that
i discriminate every time i go out to
dinner
as to what i would like to eat okay
active discrimination
would be saying that a black person
cannot go into a white person bathroom
okay that is active discrimination
saying that a man should go to a man's
bathroom
and should not go into a women's
bathroom that's not discrimination
that's called being reasonable
in fact it was precisely this objection
that originally sunk
the proposed constitutional amendment
right the era the equal rights amendment
there are people on the right who said
this is going to lead directly to the
end
of men's and women's bathrooms and
people who were promoting the era at the
time were like no
we'll never do that well we're here
again that's where we are the house
passed this bill
the bills that was will be blocked by
the by the senate
undoubtedly because you can't pass this
thing through reconciliation so it's
going nowhere
it is likely also unconstitutional
because it doesn't make any sort of
religious carve outs but the truth is
that it should be unconstitutional
because it violates freedom of
association
you should be allowed to associate with
people you want to associate with this
is a core freedom and i may not like
how you use that freedom but i'm in
favor of freedoms even if i don't like
how you use them
i'm in favor of freedom of speech even
if you are saying bad things with that
freedom of speech with which i do not
agree
i'm in favor of freedom of the press
even for places like cnn and msnbc but
this is the difference between people on
the right and people on the left
i like right even when people i don't
like are exercising those rights in ways
i do not like
if you are on the left everything is
either banned or mandatory there is no
middle category
good things are mandatory and bad things
are banned according to the left
and they've determined that it is very
bad to say that men are men and women
are women
and we must we must train every
institutional gun in america
on anybody who would note this basic
biological fact that men exist
and women exist and human beings being a
mammalian species
are dichotomous in their sex that they
are men and there are women
and the proof of this is that the
procreation of the human species relies
upon the differences the biological
differences
not the subjective self-assessment
differences the biological differences
between men and women we're going to
ignore all that
and pass what is a truly egregious and
authoritarian act the equality act is an
authoritarian bit of legislation
let me get to all the flaws with the
equality act in one second
because of course democrats propose
every bit of authoritarianism
under the guise of tolerance and it's
tolerance and diversity for their point
of view
it is shut the hell up or we will
prosecute you and or fine you
if you have a differing point of view
we'll get to what the equality act
actually does in just one second first
when you're running a business hr issues
can absolutely kill you wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations
and hr managers salaries are not cheap
they're an average of 70 000 bucks a
year
bambi is spelled b-a-m-b-e and it was
created specifically for small business
you can get a dedicated hr manager you
can craft hr policy you can maintain
your compliance all for just 99 bucks a
month
with bambi you can change hr from your
biggest liability to your biggest
strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat
from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business
and help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99 bucks a month
it's month to month there are no hidden
fees you can cancel any time you didn't
start your business because you wanted
to spend time
on hr compliance let bambi help get your
free hr audit today head on over to
bambi.com right now to schedule that
free hr audit that is bambi.com
shapiro hr issues they're very important
they can really hurt your business if
you don't get them taken care of this is
why you need bambi
spell b-a-m-b-e-e dot com shapiro
bambi.com shapiro go check them out
right now
and get that free hr audit when you do
okay so what does the equality act
actually do so ryan anderson who has
been basically book burned by amazon
they took down his book when harry
became sally
even though it is a it is a well-written
concise and yes tolerant book about
transgenderism
he says over and over and over that
people who suffer from gender dysphoria
should be treated
with the greatest of care which is
absolutely true
it is a semblance of how idiotic our
society has become that we now say that
a man with a mental disorder namely
gender dysphoria is a woman
okay that is that is not how that works
and yes it is a mental disorder
according to the dsm-4
gender dysphoria is a mental disorder
according to the dsm-5 by the way
it used to be called gender identity
dysphoria a gender identity disorder
then they renamed it gender dysphoria
because they added a requirement
in the dsm-5 the diagnostic and
statistical manual 5
that it's not just that you identify as
a member of the opposite sex it's that
it causes you depression which is the
dumbest
standard for diagnosing a mental illness
ever a mental disorder ever
by that standard if you walk around
saying that you are jesus christ
today you are not suffering from any
sort of mental disorder unless it also
causes you distress to say that
okay that's a ridiculous standard it
doesn't hold by virtually any other
definition
of a mental disorder but that is what
the
the pseudoscientists over at the
american psychological association have
to say about all of us in any case
what exactly does the equality act do so
ryan anderson writes about this
the act updates the law congress passed
primarily to combat racism the civil
rights act of 1964
and adds sexual orientation and gender
identity as protected class is akin to
race
so if you have any reservations about
gender ideology as even many
progressives do you'd now be the legal
equivalent of bull conor right to say
that men and women exist and that they
are separate
and that a man who believes he is a
woman is not actually a woman and that a
man who enters a women's locker room
with all the male appendages and says he
is a woman should not be allowed to do
so this makes you
like a 1960s jim crow-era racist
okay now to suggest that the differences
between black people and white people
are anywhere akin to the differences
between men and women is patently crazy
the differences between black people and
white people do not matter they're
essentially skin deep
that is the whole point the difference
between men and women
is a lot more than skin deep it affects
nearly every area of intersexual
relationships it affects
how men and women develop physically it
affects how men and women
developmentally there are significant
differences in mental development
between men and women
women have advantages in some areas men
have advantages in some areas but there
are major differences
this is all well-established science
there is not a single thing i am saying
right now that is conjecture
what is conjecture is the suggestion
that sex is completely malleable
what the left has done here is they play
a game here's how the game works
they accept supposedly that sex is
non-malleable
then they say gender is different from
sex so what is gender gender is a
collection of stereotypes
about femininity and masculinity okay
but now that they're stereotypes
you're saying that they're arbitrary
right because they're stereotypes
they're not connected to any sort of
underlying biological reality
and yet you say that gender is so
important and so real
that those stereotypes actually make you
a man or a woman so now
sex doesn't matter right so sex which is
the only thing that we can objectively
tell
that doesn't matter because gender
identity which a second ago
was a set of stereotypes that were
supposedly foisted upon you by an
intolerant society
those are the only things that matter so
if a man cross-dresses and dresses up as
a woman
then this makes him transgender
interested perhaps
right maybe he's actually a girl but it
depends on his self-definition if he's a
man who just likes wearing a dress
then for sure he's just a man but if
he's a man who likes wearing a dress and
also thinks he's a woman then he is a
transgender person
if none of this makes any scientific
sense to you that's because it has
nothing to do with science
it is in fact an ideology it is not in
fact scientifically rooted
it is it is based entirely on the
fallacy that sexual that
biological sex and gender
characteristics are completely different
and yet gender characteristics matter
more than biological sex and then what
you'll see is the final move which says
well actually we're gonna go back to
that whole thing about sexual dichotomy
it doesn't exist
so you'll see this from the left a lot
you see you know there are people who
have xx chromosomes or xy chromosomes
and who manifest as a member of the
other sex
because of a developmental disorder yes
it's called the developmental disorder
if if i say that human beings
walk upright that that is a true
statement
now are there certain human beings who
are born with a disability and cannot
walk upright yes does that mean that as
a class of human beings human beings do
not walk upright no
it means that some people have disorders
okay that does not mean that you
redefine
that exact term okay what what what
people on the left like to do is take
edge cases
right they like to take genetic
anomalies
and then treat those as though this
creates entire new classes of human
beings this is incorrect
it is not right it it's it's all
it's all ridiculous but this has become
the new normal so now they're trying to
enshrine this into law and this has some
pretty dire ramifications for your
freedoms
everything from freedom of association
to freedom of religion to freedom of the
press to freedom of speech all of it is
going to be ground down
under the boot heel of an authoritarian
left that decides that basic truth
should be verboten
okay it is a basic truth that men and
women exist and exist on the basis of
biological characteristics that are
objectively verifiable
that is a simple reality if you die
today
there will be people 100 years from now
who will be able to look at your dna and
they will be able to tell whether you're
a man or a woman and your subjective
self-identification will matter not one
wit
because all you will be at that point is
bones we will be able to know whether
you are in fact a man or a woman
simply by looking at your bone structure
we do this right now in archaeology
we can tell what sex your baby is before
they are born
according to left by the way you can't
tell somebody's actual gender until they
die
and even then you can't use their
biology because your gender could switch
any minute
there are people who are 45 years old
who have been a man all their life and
have sired seven children
and if they decide they're a woman they
were not only are they a woman they were
always a woman
because not only does transgender
ideology violate the boundaries of
biology it violates the boundaries of
physics it's incredible it's a time
machine
you have to erase every vestige of the
idea that this person was ever a man
right it's not just that bruce jenner
changed his name and became caitlyn
jenner and had some surgeries
that is not what happened kate bruce
jenner was always caitlyn jenner bruce
jenner was always a woman
you see while winning medals at the
olympics which makes him the most
accomplished female athlete ever by the
way
right so it turns out that biological
men are even the best female athletes
it's incredible
but now this is going to be written into
law and it's you are going to be
cudgelled with it and your children
will be cuddled with it let's not
pretend that this is anything but what
it is it's an authoritarian move by the
left
to cuddle everyone into line it's an
exercise of absolute raw power that is
the attempt right here
okay we'll get to what this actually
means on a practical level in just one
second first
let's talk about life insurance so the
reality is if god forbid something would
happen to you your family
would not be taken care of if you didn't
have life insurance that's why every
responsible adult should in fact have
life insurance
policy genius can help you check off two
big items with ease you can compare life
insurance rates
and you can save 50 or more in the
process that means more cash to put
toward the things you care about
whatever that may be
plus there's no hassle they're licensed
experts work for you not the insurance
companies so they can offer unbiased
advice when you need it
here's how it works first head on over
to policygenius.com in minutes you can
work out how much coverage you need and
compare quotes from top insurers to find
your best price
policy genius will then compare policies
starting at as little as a buck a day
you might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they will take care
of everything soup to nuts
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across over
1600 reviews
on trustpilot and google if you're
worried that march is just around the
corner you haven't gotten anything done
well here is something you can check off
that list and it's really important head
on over to policy genius right now
you could say 50 or more by comparing
quotes and feel good knowing your loved
ones would be taken care of if anything
were to happen head on over to
policygenius.com
to get started okay so as ryan anderson
writes
rather than finding common sense
narrowly tailored ways to shield lgbt
identifying americans from truly unjust
discrimination
the bill would act as a sword to
persecute those who don't embrace
newfangled gender ideologies it would
vitiate a sex binary that is quite
literally written into our genetic code
and is fundamental to many of our laws
not least laws protecting the equality
safety and privacy of women
and one of the self-defeating notions of
the transgender movement
and and the and the combination which is
really bizarre between lgb and t
right t is not like those others the
others are sexual orientations
t is a gender identity that's a
different thing
okay and not only is it a different
thing it militates directly against
the notion that men and women are
different which is one of the bases
of lgb thinking right because you have
decided that you are not
sexually attracted to one sex you are
sexually attracted to another sex or you
have been
or you're oriented that way by your
genetic code whatever it is
okay but that relies on the idea that
men and women are different
feminism relies on the idea that men and
women are different t relies on the idea
that men and women are precisely and
absolutely the same in every single way
it is just all in your head this is why
you end up with these bizarre articles
every so often from the left-wing press
in which there will be a transgender
woman meaning a biological man
calling a man who does not want to have
sex with a biological man
a person who is not straight because
this biological man
now identifies as a woman you're not
truly straight unless you want to have
sex with a transgender woman
who has a penis right if this sounds
confusing it's because it's asinine
it makes no sense at all it is
completely and utterly ridiculous
it's not just a pretzeling of logic it
is a twisting of logic into a gordian
knot that even alexander couldn't cut
so what is ryan anderson says he says
the equality act would sacrifice the
hard-won rights of women
while privileging men who identify as
women if it becomes law
such men would have the right to spend
the night in battered women's shelters
which sounds
great perfect just awesome disrobe in
women's locker rooms and compete on
women's sports teams
even at k-12 schools don't believe me
here's the text quote an individual
shall not be denied access to a shared
facility including a restroom a locker
room and a dressing room
that is in accordance with the
individual's gender identity so
you can keep separate facilities for men
and women but you have to redefine what
men and women
are and again if somebody says that they
are a member of the opposite sex you
just have to take their word for it
because there is no
objectively verifiable standard to tell
right they've removed all objectivity
it's all subjectivity all the way down
the act would massively expand the
government's regulatory reach
the equality act would coerce any
establishment that provides a good
service or program including a store
shopping center online retailer or
service provider salon bank gas station
food bank service or care center shelter
travel agency or funeral parlor
or establishment that provides
healthcare accounting or legal services
along with any organization that
receives any federal funding and
religious institutions are included
under the equality act religious schools
adoption agencies and other charities
would face federal sanction
for upholding the teachings of
mainstream biology and the bible modern
genetics in genesis when it comes to sex
and marriage
which means that your church could see
its non-profit status removed
or it could be hit with a bunch of fines
because your church refuses to say that
a man is a woman and a woman is a man
and teach it's kids at religious schools
where my kid goes to a religious day
school
i'm not going to send my kids to a
school where they teach a woman where
they teach my
where they teach my kindergartner that a
man is a woman and a woman is a man
because not only is it biologically
false it confuses children
and it makes them unhappy okay that is
teaching kids
lies and confusing them about their own
biol biology
is not just idiocy it is dangerous
idiocy
outrageously the equality act explicitly
exempts itself from the religious
freedom restoration act
pope francis would be treated as the
legal equivalent of jim crow
segregationist and it gets worse
according to ryan anderson medical
doctors secular and religious whose
expert judgment is that sex reassignment
procedures are misguided would now run
afoul of civil rights law
if you perform a mastectomy for breast
cancer now you would be forced by
federal law
to perform a mastectomy for a 15 year
old girl
who wants to be a boy all in the name of
equality and
the act refuses to and the truth the act
treats any refusal to offer abortion
as pregnancy discrimination decades of
conscience protections against abortion
extremism would be undermined so if
you're a doctor you say i don't perform
abortions they say
you're discriminating on the basis of
pregnancy this is madness
and this is what democrats are pushing
forward and calling it equality in the
process
in a second i'm gonna get to what is the
ideological basis for this where is this
coming from because there are some deep
ideological
roots here and then we'll see how it
manifests which is totally crazy
okay so here is is where all of this
comes from
over the course of last century and a
half there has been a shift
in terms of how people view themselves
there's a point made
by a philosopher named robert bella
the the basic idea is that it used to be
the enlightenment idea of enlightenment
liberalism
is that individuals mattered right
before that you were just seen as a
member of a community only
if you go back to aristotle and
aristotle would talk about
you as a member of the palace right that
your value was in your value to the
to the political community that
surrounded you and in religious
communities there were some of this as
well right your value was as a member of
the tribe
so to speak okay enlightenment
liberalism
fixated on a couple of things they said
number one you have the individual
ability to reason
your reason is supposed to pursue virtue
right this very greek idea
at the same time the bible says that
every individual is created in the image
of god
this creates individual rights so
enlightenment liberalism was predicated
on the notion that government should
treat you as an individual
and you should be treated as an
individual right this is the basis for
all of our politics now
but there is an unspoken assumption
which is that in treating you as an
individual
your job your duty right the other side
of the right the other side of the
rights that that
adhered to you by didn't have the laws
of nature and nature's god
is that would you you would use that
liberty to pursue virtue
you would use your reason in order to
persevere to pursue virtue and be a
better person
this is why removing the judeo-christian
roots of the enlightenment
ends up with radicalism because when we
remove the duty to be a good person
or a virtuous person when you remove all
of that all you end up with
is just your belief that as an
individual you are entitled to define
the world in any way you want and you
see this in language
from people like justice anthony kennedy
who suggested in an abortion case
right planned parenthood versus casey he
suggested that you have a right to
define the universe and the meaning of
life in any way that you want
okay well that is all fun and games up
until the point where you demand
that i accept and tolerate your meaning
of life
right that i accept your version of
reality
this is what robert bella talked about
he called it expressive individualism
there's a difference between
enlightenment individualism which
recognizes that yes you have rights as
an individual but you ought to use those
rights
in order to exercise your reason and
persevere and pursue
virtue typically in judeo-christian
sense and expressive individualism
expressive individualism
completely disconnects you from the
community at large it creates you as an
atomic individual right you're
you're an atomistic individual rather
you're you're a separate
individual from the rest of the
community and the only thing that
matters is how you define the world
expressive individualism is the basic
idea that the goal of life
and of government ought to be ensuring
the ability of individuals to explore
their own perception of the good life
and to express it as they see fit in any
way
enlightenment liberalism as i say was
built atop a basis
of notions about greek virtue and
judeo-christian decency
okay but that was removed over the
course of time expressive individualism
obliterates those limits
so if you find if you find meaning in
avoiding responsibility
and living as basically a teenager in
your entire life that is just fine and
no one can judge you for it
if you find meaning in ignoring your
kids nobody can really judge you for
that because
after all you don't have a duty duties
don't accrue duties are an element of
virtue
if you find meaning in defining yourself
in a way that is directly contrary to
either reality or decency that is also
liberty so if you decide
that you are a man when you are a woman
or that you are a woman when you are a
man that is just you defining reality
for yourself it's expressive
individualism
because the goal of life is to express
yourself it's all about authenticity it
is not about duty
it's not about decency it's not about
reason it's about finding your authentic
self
and here's the thing there's a corollary
okay anybody
who stops you from expressing yourself
this way
is an obstacle anybody who stops you
from expressing yourself this way is a
problem
and we don't even mean rules that stop
you from acting the way we want
we mean anybody who refuses to
acknowledge your reality as
reality writ large is a problem for you
oh carter sneed philosophy professor at
university of notre dame
says that according to philosopher
charles taylor individualism expressive
individualism requires the approval of
others
taylor quote identified a new category
of harm that emerges in a culture of
expressive individualism namely
the failure to receive accept and
appreciate the expression of others
inner depths
to fail to recognize the expression of
other selves is a violation and a harm
to them right because after all your
deepest belief system
is what we all seek in life and if
people refuse to acknowledge that your
belief system is reality
then this means they have infringed upon
you so if you choose to use
the pronoun g and i say nope
you're a dude then i have infringed upon
you
i've infringed upon you in such an
egregious way that the federal
government should step in and regulate
it
now as you may notice expressive
individualism neglects a simple fact
which is that many people define reality
in a different way in a libertarian
libertarian universe
we would be able to acknowledge that
some people define reality in a certain
way but i don't have a responsibility to
accept
that in my life i don't have a
responsibility to accept unreality as
reality
but the left wing believes that only
secular expressive individualism matters
which is why religious
conscience protections can be
overwritten which is why basic biology
can be overwritten because all that
matters is what is in the heart of the
individual and if you refuse to accept
their reality
you are imposing on them right this is
the this is the
completely backwards world in which we
live there's only one group here who's
pointing the government gun at somebody
and it is the advocates of the equality
act people on the right are not pointing
the government gun at anybody
it is people on the left who are
demanding that you acquiesce
to a biological unreality that you
acquiesce
to an ideological ridiculous notion an
ideologically silly notion
a self-contradictory notion by the way
and that if you do not they will point
the government gun at you
and then say that you are the intolerant
non-accepting one
the answer to all of this should be no
but you'll see how this
plays out and it does play out this way
you'll see who gets shellacked in public
life
for saying true things and who gets
rewarded for saying false things
we'll get to that in just one second
first we have now made it to friday
we're nearly to the end of the month
which means this is your very last
chance
to take advantage of the february deals
over at beard
supply now we here at daily wire we have
a number of famous beards
right we have jeremy boring's beard we
have matt walsh's magnificent beardiness
and a lot of beards over here at the at
the daily wire and each one of them
has been hand crafted by the folks over
at beard supply if you want your beard
to grow out in style which is exactly
what beard supplies all natural all
awesome beard oils will help you do
you have to head on over to
beardsupply.com
and make your selection right now you
can go shop their feb
harry deal today buy one get one 50 off
on all
of their magnificent beard oils be like
a magnificent viking king
go head over to beardsupply.com make
your selection the discount is only good
for the next 48 hours
no promo code is necessary just head on
over to beardsupply.com and jen's
since this is the last time of the year
i can say this happy february
now go treat yourself to some beard oils
and be
like all of the manly men in your past
grow out that beard and make sure that
you use the beard oil that makes it the
best beard it can be
go check out beardsupply.com right now
okay so again there are foundational
legal problems with the equality act
it is outside the scope of typical
non-discrimination law
it is a deliberate attempt to shut down
all debate
on an issue where the facts do not side
with the left
and and people this is authoritarian
stuff it truly is
so for example when asked whether there
should be a religious exemption whether
religious people should be able to teach
their children that men and women are
different
people who are advocates to this bill
say no absolutely not we want to teach
your children
we must teach your children in fact not
only that we must make your church
do what we want your church to do we
must make you as a religious person
abandon your religious principles by the
way
if you actually want things to get
incredibly ugly in this country start
seriously infringing religious liberty
rights
religious people have a very very long
history of resisting
government intervention into their
religious lives
and they happen to be right okay the the
reality is that if you have a deeply
held belief
about god and the nature of decency and
then you have people who are insisting
that they cram down their version of
decency on your children
you're going to run into some resistance
there and you ought to because this is
authoritarian bullcrap
and here is a an lgbtq plus reporter
from the 19th
kate sosen talking about religious
exemptions
the equality act tries to
insert protections for lgbtq people into
the civil rights act of 1964
so um you know people are protected on
the basis of race you can't
turn away a black person from a
restaurant
um and the same thing will be true for
a gay person if you put religious
exemptions
into that bill you're opening up a can
of worms right
so this is going to be the sticking
point oh it's a can of worms is it see
religious liberty and freedom of
association
and freedom of speech by the way all of
this is just a can of worms
no you know what opens up the can of
worms trying to cram down a one size
anti-reality fits all
rule on every american because by the
way this has free speech ramifications
too
we've already seen this in like the new
york city human rights council has
suggested that if you misgender somebody
they are going to find you so in other
words if i call somebody by their
biological pronouns just like humans
have done
throughout nearly all of human history
then this means
that i have actively discriminated
against you for saying a true thing
now by the way people have asked me
about this all the time do you use
transgender pronouns you use
what they call preferred pronouns which
is not preferred right it's i require
you to use it it's mandatory pronouns
right is it because they're not
preferred right you don't make the
preference
it is that you require somebody else to
use it right i have a preference to do x
i if i have a preference that you do x
that is a mandate that that is now a
requirement upon you
okay that is the lie about the term
preferred pronouns it's not that i
prefer that you use this pronoun it's if
you don't use this pronoun your
discriminatory tool bag
it's a requirement that i do something
all of this is euphemistic garbage in
any case
the basic idea here people have asked
about using these sorts of pronouns and
here's what i've said if i'm at dinner
with a transgender person i'll call them
whatever
they want i don't care because that's
just being polite
but when i just this is my basic rule
when i discuss people
in general you know when i'm speaking
about them on a broad
level when i'm speaking about politics i
refuse to use
pronouns that do not apply to the
biological sex i will not do that
because words have meaning
i'm not just going to not use words that
have meaning on the basis that
somebody's feelings might be heard
because guess what that is public policy
and that is politics and that is reality
sometimes the facts don't jibe with your
feelings sometimes the facts are just
what the facts are
and i'm happy to be polite and treat you
with the utmost courtesy
when we are in a personal situation i've
gone out to dinner with transgender
people to make sure that they are doing
okay
after a lecture of mine for example this
happened when i was in canada
had breakfast with a transgender person
who was unhappy with how an exchange
went the previous night in a particular
speech got together with this person
used whatever pronouns this person
wanted but when it comes to is that
person a man or a woman
that person is their biological sex end
of story okay but this makes you bad
because again you are violating somebody
else's expressive individualism
so marjorie taylor green right now is
the person who is getting shellacked
over all this now
as you know i'm not a marjorie taylor
green fan i've spoken out against her
i've suggested that censure might be
appropriate for some of the comments
that she has made in the past including
about jewish space lasers okay
but she happened not to have started
this entire exchange
over transgenderism so what happened is
that there's a congresswoman in marie
newman
and marie newman gave a speech on the
house floor in which
she talked about her transgender
daughter meaning her biological son
and suggested that because she has a
biological son who believes that he is a
woman
this means that we ought to mandate all
across the land that everybody simply
overthrow basic notions of human biology
and sexual dichotomy
right this is this is what she had to
say on the floor of the house and again
i feel bad for her as a mother
i feel bad for her son as a son right
that you can have enormous sympathy for
people who are suffering with gen for
gender
with gender dysphoria and you should
have sympathy for them you should treat
them decently that is not the same thing
as mandating that hundreds of millions
of americans buy
into the overt lie that men are women
and women are men and it is all
it is all just a matter of self
assessment you take a little quiz
every day and determine whether you're a
man or woman that's absurd in any case
here is congresswoman marie newman
i rise today on behalf of the millions
of americans who
continue to be denied housing education
public services
and much much more because they identify
as members of the lgbtq community
americans like my own daughter who years
ago bravely came out to her parents as
transgender
i knew from that day on my daughter
would be living in a nation where most
of it states
she could be discriminated against
merely because of who she is
and yet it was still the happiest day of
my life
okay so in any case this is what she
said and you have to have sympathy for
her and have
sympathy for her son and again you
shouldn't mistreat people
based on the fact that they suffer from
gender dysphoria of course okay all of
that is perfectly clear and by the way
there would be a tailored way to do some
of these things but they're not
interested in doing this in a tailored
way obviously
okay so marjorie taylor green tweeted
out and this happens to be correct
as much broken clocks can be right
people i don't like can be right
marjorie taylor green tweeted out as
mothers we all love and support our
children
but your biological son does not belong
in my daughter's bathrooms locker rooms
and sports teams
all right that seems like a perfectly
fine tweet
frankly i i don't disagree with any
element of that right
that is it that is a perfectly decent
tweet we are talking about public policy
here
right when it comes to shaping law you
have to have in mind what the actual
legal standard is going to be
okay well this resulted in congresswoman
marie newman
just posturing for the camera so she
decides that she is going to
take a transgender flag and walk over to
marjorie taylor green's office which is
across the hall
and plant the transgender flag outside
marjory taylor green's office
right so she she posts a transgender
flag right outside her
own office right and so marjorie taylor
green goes outside her office
and she posts a sign that says there are
two genders male and female
trust the science okay so the clap back
is where people are getting
getting angry of course because you see
when you
impose on somebody else a biological
falsehood
this is not considered an imposition
this is considered expressive
individualism
if you say biology exists this is
considered an imposition
marjorie taylor green did not start that
particular exchange on social media
it was congresswoman marie newman who
did but the villain today of course in
the media is margery taylor green there
are plenty of reasons why people don't
like margery taylor green
this is not one of them okay this is not
one of them
in a second we're gonna get to the most
absurd exchange over all of this
the villain of the day now is rand paul
okay i'll explain
why this is just not only not only
screwed up to make rand paul the villain
in this particular situation
but our society has a deep and serious
illness if it believes that rand paul is
the bad guy in this particular situation
we'll get to this
in just one second first as we saw
in texas recently after what we see in
california routinely nobody can deny
how vulnerable we very often are the
power grid failure severe weather they
made the food supply chain
come to a grinding hall in many parts of
the country last week whenever that
happens people suffer that's why it is
smart
to prepare in advance for disaster by
stocking up on long-term storage
emergency food
food that stays fresh for up to 25 years
so you're never going to go hungry i
strongly recommend
my patriot supply it's america's leader
in self-reliance they're the only source
we use for emergency food planning
right now you can save 50 bucks off four
week kits of delicious meals that give
you a 2 000 plus calories a day
that's exactly what you're going to need
in order to survive at the next disaster
again planning for disaster the
government tells you to do it
okay so there's not a right left issue
the reality is that if something bad
were to happen you need to make sure
that you have enough food stored up so
that you're okay
these four-week emergency food kits ship
in one day discreetly to your door
supplies are limited so do not wait most
people aren't prepared for a disaster
but now you know and now you're thinking
about it so just go do it go to
preparewithbend.com
save 50 bucks stock up right now that's
prepare with ben.com again
prepare with ben.com go check them out
right now my patreon supply
prepare with ben dot com alrighty
in just a second we'll get to rand paul
having an exchange that just exposes
how our society honestly we may be rev
irrevocably broken you may be
irrevocably broken first
it is that glorious time of the week
when i give a shout out to a daily wire
member today
it is fry saucy on twitter who perfectly
sums up our newest collies last few
weeks
in the picture actress gina chrono's
action figure from the mandalorian
stands confidently on top of the world's
greatest beverage vessel the caption
reads
gina as cara doon on her supply of
hashtag leftist ears
at ben shapiro hashtag left is tears
tumblr in a follow-up tweet fry saucy
writes my husband asked me to tweet it
because he's anti-twitter
your husband is right twitter is indeed
a hellscape that picture was worth the
tweet thanks for the shout out
and for being a daily wear member by the
way tens of thousands of people joining
like pretty much every single week here
at daily weather become one of them
we are launching a new show exclusively
for daily wear members this is so cool
okay so there's a simple highly
effective rule for making a good good
argument do not build it on a fallacy
the left doesn't care about this
particular rule that is why we are going
to be
destroying destroying through facts and
logic those particular
fallacies every single friday in 15
minutes or less exclusively for our
members only for our members is not
available to the general public
in our new series debunked every week i
will take facts
and logic and i'll put them up against a
popular leftist argument the kind you
see your friends post and share all over
the internet
whether we are talking about transgender
ideology or universal healthcare i'm
going to help you completely dismantle
these arguments so if you're not already
a dailywire member head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe use code
debunked to get 25
off the first episode is dropping soon
as in i think today right so head on
over to dailywire.com
subscribe today like do it today use
code debunked for 25
off to access my brand new series i'm
going to give you all the arguments that
you need
to fight at the water cooler and on
social media and to really know what
you're talking about go over to
dailywire.com
subscribe today use code debunked for 25
off you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so the latest example of
authoritarians treating
non-authoritarians as the villain
is this exchange between rand paul and
rachel levine so rachel levine is most
famous
for being the transgender former head of
the
health services in in pennsylvania
and as former head of the health
services in pennsylvania dr levine
took this person's mother out of the
nursing home while simultaneously
shipping coveted positive people back
into nursing homes this person has no
qualifications whatsoever
i mean truly no this is the thing that
this person is most famous for
other than being a transgender person
upon the announcement of rachel levine
as a undersecretary nominee a deputy
secretary nominee
all of the press releases were like
transgender doctor nominated okay last i
checked i don't care whether a doctor is
trans or not i care whether that doctor
is capable of providing the care that is
necessary in any case rand paul
asked this person who wants to be the
biden nominee
for undersecretary of health and human
services deputy secretary of health and
human services
asked a very simple question as
secretary of health and human services
are you in favor of for using the
government
to force parents to ignore when their
children
are undergoing hormone treatment or
gender disfiguring surgery i mean
that seems like a pretty easy answer
there right
and so here is rand paul questioning dr
rachel levine
and of course this makes rand paul the
villain you see because rand fall is
considered transphobic
for saying that perhaps you know like 11
year olds should not be given
hormone treatments in the absence in the
absence of parental approval
this makes rand paul a transphobe
if folks on the authoritarian left say
they're not coming for the kids this is
a pretty good example of how
they are perfectly welcoming for the
kids and if you question them about it
then they get very upset
dr levine do you believe that minors are
capable of making such a life-changing
decision as changing one's
sex well senator thank you for your
interest in this question um transgender
medicine
is a very complex and nuanced field
um with robust research and standards of
care that have been developed
will you make a more firm decision on
whether or not minors should be involved
in these decisions
senator transgender medicine is a very
complex
and nuanced field let it go into the
record that the witness refused to
answer the question
okay and that is a very simple question
right your kid comes home and says that
he is a girl and you say okay well i
want to do watchful waiting which is
the proper response right because the
vast majority of kids don't end up
actually suffering from gender dysphoria
the vast majority of kids are confused
some of them end up being gay right i
mean and they end up
having a different sexual orientation
but that doesn't manifest as
they are a member of the opposite sex or
think they are a member of the opposite
sex
there's pretty solid evidence to this to
this proposal
in any case here is a thing that should
never happen in any
free society people who are under the
age of 18 can't get a tylenol from the
school nurse but now you're saying that
a boy
can walk into the school nurse and the
government should just give that kid
an estrogen pill or go further and allow
transgender surgery for that kid or take
the kid away from the parents if the
parents refuse to go along with that
kind of stuff
okay so that's what rand paul is asking
rachel levine about and rachel levine's
response is i'm not going to answer that
question
that's an insane answer an insane answer
i mean it's it's child abuse what we are
talking about is government-sponsored
child abuse government
mandated child abuse
right rand paul began questioning levine
about genital mutilation of minors which
by the way
these surgeries are okay you can say
that the surgeries
are something that a person of majority
status might want
it's a free country you can do that but
to determine anything other than genital
mutilation
to remove the actual genitals of a man
and then carve out of that man a fake
vagina
there's no other way to characterize
that other than genital mutilation
that's what it is now
again should adults be able to do that
if they want to do that
i'm a libertarian do what you want i
don't think it's just
i don't think it's uh the evidence that
this has a particularly salutary effect
on your future
is extraordinarily scanty if i were a
doctor i would not perform these sorts
of surgeries because of that lack of
evidence
i think these surgeries are immoral but
adults are free to do what adults do
but if you're talking about doing that
to a child you're talking about doing
that to a child
i mean i don't understand how
rand paul talking about genital
mutilation of child makes rand paul the
bad guy
paul said genital mutilation has been
universally condemned genital mutilation
is considered particularly egregious
because as the who notes it is nearly
always
carried out on minors and is a violation
of the rights of children
he said american culture is now
normalizing the idea that miners can be
given hormones to prevent biological
development of their secondary sexual
characteristics that'd be puberty
blockers
by the way this is now being treated as
standard of care by the left not
watchful waiting
if you say listen kids should be able to
grow into their puberty and they should
become adults before they make these
decisions
this apparently is a massive imposition
on an 11 year old who knows nothing
about puberty who knows nothing
about sexual orientation who knows
nothing about what it is like to develop
as a man or a woman
so watchful waiting is out the window
instead what we ought to be pursuing is
active puberty blockers we have no idea
what the long-term effects of these
things are
they're off label as rand paul points
out this makes rand paul a bad guy
he said dr levine have supported both
allowing minors to be given hormone
blockers to prevent them from going
through puberty as well as surgical
destruction of a minor genitalia
okay and this apparently makes him bad
this makes him super bad
okay it's just it's incredible so when
you
ask about authoritarianism here who's
the authoritarian the guy who says we
should not
overrule parents and allow the
government to force parents
to let children mutilate their own
genitals or have puberty blockers
we don't know the long-term side effects
or do any the government should step in
and do it
who's the authoritarian here in a
society that values expressive
individualism
above basic human decency the person
who is striving for basic human decency
is now seen as indecent that is why
things are completely
and utterly upside down all right we'll
be back here later today with an
additional hour of the ben shapiro show
first you cannot forget to end your week
by checking out the andrew clavin show
drew is back every friday he's got an
exciting night planned for you so head
on over to dailywire.com this evening at
7 pm eastern and tune in
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producers are
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing
the end of days is approaching and the
moons turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way through the fall of the
republic with me
andrew clavin